hi everyone welcome to the simplyland
youtube channel this session will be
about see python before we begin if you
love watching tech videos subscribe to
our channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update
in this session you will learn about
what c python is
next you will come to know whether
python is interpreted or compiled
language
further you will know about the history
of c python and learn about the basics
of source code of c python
you will understand the working of c
python and know why c python written in
c and not python
let's start with c python
the default implementation of the python
programming language is c python and it
is one of the python runtimes
it is directly downloaded from
python.oig in programming language c and
it also executes the programming
language python let's know about its
history
so the first version of c python was
released in 1994 by the python developer
community
now let's brush up some basic concepts
first one is the python programming
language it is a high level general
purpose programming language if we talk
in general the programming language only
describes how to express yourself to the
interpreter
that is the program which accepts the
python code
the next is implementation
it is all about how the interpreter was
written specifically in what language
and what it ends up doing the next is
machine code machine code it is set of
instructions that directly gets executed
by the cpu
almost all the high level languages such
as c translate the source code into
executable machine code with the help of
compilers loaders and linkers
the next concept we'll learn is bytecode
bytecode it's the code that is processed
by a program usually referred to as a
virtual machine rather than the real
computer machine
and moreover the machine code is much
faster as compared to bytecode but
bytecode is portable and secure as
compared to machine code
now let's get to know whether python is
interpreted or compiled language
we have read that python is an
interpreted language but the truth is
that it is both compiled and interpreted
language
before moving ahead let's brush up the
concepts of compilation and
interpretation first we'll start with
compilation
it's the process in which the source
code is translated into the machine
readable code or it serves as the input
to another compiler or interpreter it
takes whole code file as an input the
code is translated once into object code
and can be run many times it will not
execute the machine readable code it
produced
the next we'll learn about is
interpretation
interpretation it's the process that
takes a single line of code at a time
and executes it
interpreter executes the instructions
specified in the source code while the
program gets executed now we will see
both compilation and interpretation in
one diagram
many programming languages don't compile
to actual machine code but to a byte
code
the compiler first compiles the source
code to an intermediate language called
bytecode which is the low level platform
independent representation of the source
code
the virtual machine that is interpreter
then takes the byte code and executes it
now let's move ahead and see some basic
concepts of source code of c python
the c python source distribution comes
with a whole range of tools libraries
and components
to compile c python from the source code
you need a c compiler and some build
tools according to your os
to download a copy of the c python
source code you can use git to pull the
latest version to a working copy locally
now let's understand the working of c
python c python ends up producing byte
code
which is python specific and then it
executes it
the reason to convert python code to
bytecode is because it's easier to
implement an interpreter if it's look
like machine instructions
but it isn't necessary to produce some
byte code prior to execution
so we will understand this with the help
of an example
first the compiler receives the source
code it then checks the syntax of each
line in the source code if the compiler
encounters an error it holds the
translation process with an error
message else if the transaction is well
formatted then it translates the python
source code into a special low-level
intermediary language called bytecode
this byte code is stored in dot pyc
files that is hidden in a directory and
cached for execution and only understood
by c python bytecode is sent to the
python virtual machine that is pvm
python virtual machine is the part of
the python system that actually runs the
python code
that is in the format of white code it
takes the bytecode instructions one by
one and executes its section
bytecode along with its input and
library modules is given as the input to
the pvm that is python virtual machine
python virtual machine executes the byte
code and if any error occurs it displays
an error message that would be the
runtime error otherwise if there is no
error in execution it results in the
output now let's see why c python is
written in c and not in python
as c python follows source to source
compiler model
these source to source compiler models
are first written in another language
which is already possessing a compiler
we have a very good example of go
language first co-compiler was based on
c programming language as when go could
be compiled the compiler was rewritten
in go
with that we have come to the end of
this session i hope it was interesting
and informative if you liked it please
let us know in the comment section below
also do subscribe to our channel and
stay tuned for more from
simple hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here